[Music]
thank you
ladies
[Music]
now
we know
[Music]
thank you
guitar players
hello
welcome welcome all you on time people
gold stars
gold stars here and those of you joining
us online
to the table my name is Karen it is so
good to see all of your faces
um it is still a New Year we're at the
halfway point of January which is hard
to believe but
stuff happening at the table in the
coming months that we'll tell you about
in the in the coming weeks for tonight
though uh I did want to mention a couple
things
first you may notice there are cards and
pens either on your seat or on the seat
next to you next to you Brett will
explain what those are during his
message and so for now you can just set
them aside and then Brett will give you
instructions on what to do with those
later
um
secondly tomorrow is Martin Luther King
Jr's birthday observed today is his
actual birthday
um I think he would have been 94 years
old today wow yeah amazing
um so I wanted to encourage all of us uh
to honor his legacy to remember him to
learn more about him I just this is my
own personal opinion I don't speak on
behalf of the table
um my personal opinion is I know my
education just like barely scratched the
surface of Martin Luther King Jr who he
was what what he was about
um a lot of people that were involved in
the civil rights movement and so
we now have the internet and we have
libraries and they're great ways to
supplement the education we got or
didn't receive so one action item uh for
those of you like teens adults I would
highly highly encourage you to read
letter from a Birmingham Jail written by
Martin Luther King Jr while he was in
jail in Birmingham and it was written
the audience was a white clergy members
and so it definitely is still relevant
to us today as church as Christian
churches in America it's an excellent
excellent read
for the younger kiddos the Wiley public
library has a path behind the library
and sometimes they will post stories
like picture books that you can read as
you walk the trail with with your
parents with your kids it's super fun
and cool and they have a book called
Martin's big words that's there right
now so you can take your kids walk
around the trail learn about Martin
Luther King Jr I think one way if you
walk the trail one way it's Martin's big
words if you walk the trail the other
way it's a big snowy day so either way
great options there and I think it's
it's going on through January 22nd so a
couple of great ways to learn more about
Martin Luther King do it like he he
deserves that he deserves us learning
about him his legacy and what he was all
about so
um let's Center ourselves and prepare
for worship tonight so if you can close
your eyes
let's start by just arriving here
take a big deep breath in
exhale
one more time in
be here now
whatever is on the to-do list can be put
on pause
let's Center our hearts and our minds
on Jesus
God we give you tonight we thank you for
your bigness how big you are how amazing
you are ways that we can't even
comprehend and at the same time how
close you are to each one of us I pray
that tonight we would sense your
presence and your nearness and your love
that it would be made real and personal
to each one of us
and God
help us to trust you at deeper levels
to be thoughtful
in the ways that we treat people
to be curious lifelong learners
to be faithful
and to really take the lead of Martin
Luther King Jr
in the ways that he was both
contemplative and took action he was so
so rooted in you God
so surrendered to you
and was willing to take steps and take
action
towards Justice and wholeness and
towards a Beloved Community
help us to mirror those ways God
help us to be courageous and brave step
outside of our comfort zones in new ways
this year
but to do so out of a place of being
fully surrendered and rooted in you God
so we thank you for the ways that you're
working in us and Among Us
we thank you for your love in Jesus name
amen
[Music]
will you guys go ahead and stand up with
us I am really excited about our time
together tonight and uh
how God can encourage us as we join into
worship together so you guys sing out
um as you can and let these words sink
deep into your hearts and encourage you
[Music]
they love you Lord
for you have delivered me
I love you Lord
for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
my feet from stumbling I will walk in
the land of the living
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
stumbling I will walk in the land of the
living
[Music]
life
look at my baby
[Music]
from stumbling I will walk in the land
of the living my soul from Death my feet
of the living
again
all right thank you guys you big kids
are dismissed and all the kids are going
to go to this front classroom tonight on
on my left you're right so
um
a worker will let you in
[Music]
you guys have fun we'll see you after
the service and we're gonna move into
um the prayers of the people now and
Maggie is going to leave us in that
would you guys read aloud with me on the
screen
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for The Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
Chelsea and Johnny Owen
[Music]
Angelina
foreign
[Music]
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and hope peace and a
deep sense of your presence amen
foreign
[Music]
and you've been so so good to me
before I took a breath you breathed your
life in me
you've been so so kind to me
[Music]
oh it chases
foreign
[Music]
me
when I felt no worth You Paid It All
over
I've been so so kind to me
no No
Reckless Love of God
[Music]
I don't deserve it still you give
yourself away
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
coming after me
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
together
[Music]
foreign
I love those words
in that bridge there's no Shadow you
won't light up there's no mountain you
won't climb up
there's no wall you won't kick down
know why you won't tear down
tonight I pray that there is nothing
that would stand between us and your
love
that nothing would separate us from you
we're about to learn a new song together
at least that we haven't done in in our
context before it's called firm
foundation and
um
one of the lines that's in the song that
I just really love it says I'm not held
by My Own Strength because I've built my
life on Jesus he's never let me down
and
I was just thinking about even some of
our stories in this room that I know
some of you have shared them from this
stage or just in relationship with each
other and um following Jesus is one of
those tricky things because on the
outside sometimes it can look like
something you want to do because maybe
you feel that God will rescue you and
save you from the storm from the wind
and the rain by allowing you to just
avoid it all together like maybe that's
the story of Jesus is that we don't have
to go through hard things at all but
actually that is not the gospel the
truth is that we still live in a very
real world and we are still very broken
people and we still experience a lot of
pain and what I love about the gospel is
that it doesn't promise that we won't go
through those things it promises that he
will be with us as we go through them
and it's our choice it's our decision to
continue to root ourselves to Anchor
ourselves into the truth of the Gospel
that he is faithful that he walks with
us that he will restore and redeem that
he will not forsake us in our darkest
moments and I pray that as we sing these
words that we would remember moments in
our own lives where we have faced the
storms where the rains and the winds
have come and in the end of it we can
say you are faithful God you have seen
us through I am still here you are still
doing your good work in my life
that's the gospel
and that's what we have to offer to this
world it's not Santa Claus it's not a
take it out of jail it's the promise of
a God who will remain faithful and see
us through so hang on to that hope hang
on root yourselves into that promise
and as we sing these words would it
transform the way that we go through
hardship would it transform the way that
we see the struggles in front of us
right now
would we be able to take hope to have
heart knowing that he's with us
[Music]
Christ is my firm foundation
Jesus
[Music]
he's never let me down he's faithful to
Generations
[Music]
got peace that makes no sense so I won't
be going Monday
for Jesus
[Music]
the only thing
you are
[Music]
Fair
[Applause]
[Music]
everything around me
I put my faith in Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
the old days
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the rain came in blue but my house was
built on you
I'm safe with you I'm gonna make it
through sing that with me
[Music]
and I'm safe with
you I'm gonna baby
blue but my house was built on you
stay away
[Music]
is built on you
I'm gonna make it through
cause I'm standing strong on you
cause my house is built on you
[Music]
foreign
would Our Hope be in the name of Jesus
in the God who doesn't leave us
in The God Who Walks through persecution
and storm and struggle and sin with us
The God Who does not give up on us
but continues to do his work in our
lives
have that hope
that Firm Foundation
and when the world around us is
crumbling when everything else is
sinking sand
would you be a rock
would we have a hope to offer to others
[Music]
Your Love Never Fails
it is faithful
thank you for being that kind of God
thank you for seeing us through
thank you for the lives in this room
who have made it through
there are people who are standing here
who have faced life and death and they
have chosen life
and we celebrate that God
would you continue to see us through
would you continue to Anchor us
be our strength our Voice of Truth
[Music]
we love you Jesus and we need you
desperately
[Music]
so keep seeing us through
it's in your name that we pray all these
things
[Music]
let's turn to the people around you and
welcome them say hello connect with each
other for a second and then Brett will
get us started on our message
thank you
[Music]
all right Grace and peace
so good to be with you all welcome to
the table and
um and it's just uh I just love I love
the rhythm of these Sundays it's just
good to good to be with you all and
um I I also want to as always welcome
those joining us online
y'all are not forgotten and
um
so anyone who is uh new or
um yeah just kind of finding your way
into the community thanks so much for
being here means means a lot to have you
and so we are we're kicking off new
series towards the beginning of the year
so uh seemed like a good time to start
something something new so the title of
our series is a rooted grounded
discipleship and you know we'll be kind
of in future this will be almost more of
a series intro this whole message which
is why the title of the message is also
the same just rooted and future weeks
we'll get a little bit more like it'll
get very practical
um this week is related a lot to church
life but um future weeks will be a
little bit different it'll be a lot of
like I wanted to be well like I said
practicals it'll be like how to's
um like how to pray or how to listen or
how to fight not like you know
this but you know I mean like verbal and
how to
um and work through conflict and and
just how to follow Christ in kind of
very practical ways so that'll be kind
of where we're where we're going in the
future uh but uh tonight we're gonna be
in Ephesians chapter 3 verses 16 through
18 and uh the Apostle Paul he writes
these words he says
so I pray that out of his glorious
riches he may strengthen you with power
through his spirit in your inner being
so that Christ May dwell in your hearts
through faith and I pray that you being
rooted
and established in love may have power
together with all the Lord's holy people
to grasp how wide and long and high and
deep is the love of Christ a very famous
passage you might recognize that ending
in particular about the long and wide
and high and deep is the love of Christ
so
I want to start here so a few thousand
years ago or I should say for the last
few thousand years the Benedictine monks
and nuns they have taken three vowels
upon entering their monastic uh
community and for those of familiar it's
the benedictines are kind of the
Catholic Christian wing of the church
and these the first two I think are like
not very shocking it's really the third
one I want to like zero in on because I
think it's so bizarre and wonderful uh
so the first one is a vow of poverty uh
which makes sense you know like
basically give up all I mean if you want
to become a monk or none
um like you like bank account is like
given away like you cannot have any
connection with money okay so actually
that is pretty radical
um but uh but it doesn't mean it makes
sense right you don't like expect
millionaire monks or something weird so
that's the first and then the second is
a vow of obedience
basically to listen to like there they
call it the Abbot or the abatus the kind
of leader of that monastic community and
which makes sense it's sort of that that
Community functions as like a community
of apprenticeship you know where you
Apprentice yourself to older kind of
wiser members in the community and so
it's basically like hey I'm not going to
be here and cause a bunch of trouble you
know I'm gonna like do what the the
older folks say
um and but the third one that's the one
I want to I want to focus in on so uh
this last one is called The Vow of
stability
and basically when that monk or none uh
commits to that community
they commit to literally be there
in that place
for the rest of their lives
like they will not leave
without breaking it out
like that's their commitment and I that
like is that pretty that's pretty
intense right I'm not like misreading it
yeah that's pretty like wow uh now what
is this why do they do this what does
this do well Benedict who of course
founded the Benedictine been asking me
way back when uh what he what he saw was
uh what a lot of amongst the nuns were
doing was they would like go to a
community they'd be there for a while
and then they would for some reason they
would get upset or like Feud with
someone or you know whatever and then
they like move on to the next community
and they like move on to the next
community and then move on you know I
mean it was like so we could just kind
of see like oh okay well this isn't
working so that's where he introduced
this this vow and what did did was it
brought some like stability
to the life of that
um that monk or that nun but also it
brought stability to that broader
Community right and uh I think of course
the valon ways it's about like it was
about more than geography though you
know just kind of reducing it to like
whoa how extreme they wouldn't leave
that place you know
um what was that really about it was in
a deeper sense like it was the
commitment to not just the place like
I'll be here and this you know five
acres or whatever but it was it was a
commitment to a community and it was a
commitment to their Christian spiritual
practice
right to to continue in that in a way
you might say this is one of the this is
actually a priest um but he had some
monastic Roots his name was Saint
francisau and his advice um to
Christians was Bloom where you are
planted
I think that's a lovely turn of phrase
Bloomer you're planted I think that's
what those old monks and nuns were doing
and continue to do it was like this
almost just this trust
you know to like okay
God this is where you called me
I'm just gonna Bloom where I'm planted
right in other words to kind of
personalize it you might say that you
and I I must learn to grow where I
implanted now how does this apply to
Ephesians 3 well you know I suspect when
Paul speaks in verse 17 of being rooted
and established in love he seems to have
this certain kind of inner groundedness
or inner rootedness in the love of
Christ so verse 17 so that Christ May
dwell in your hearts through faith and I
pray that you being rooted and
established in love so you can see there
he's it's like a very kind of inner
thing you know he's he's describing an
inward reality not necessarily something
someone could just look at you and like
I know you know you're a rooted in a
Chrysler but it's a very inner
experience uh which you know wouldn't
necessarily seem to apply much to like
our theme today and this whole
Benedictine thing
um except this is kind of the the
question that's been running through my
mind the last few weeks is that as
modern people
could our kind of struggle
to experience that kind of that inner
rootedness
in Christ in love
even just having a certain like inner
peace
of like
comfort with Who We Are Who God's made
us to be
what God's called us to do
you know that's kind of security could
that that struggle
in that inner rootedness could it be
related
to our lack of outer
rootedness
in other words could my lack of exterior
stability
be feeding
my lack of interior stability and and
again I mean this in more than simply a
geographic location sense like oh if
only we didn't move around so much as
modern folks you know then we'd have
that in original I think that's
contributing to it
um that can be a real challenge to feel
rooted when we're like moving every
three years you know
um but I really I mean in a broader
sense than that like really
um
it's about we might call it the like the
instability or the looseness of our
connections
to everything
and everyone
and everywhere
in other words it seems that we are the
people of just a million different
options
aren't we like we have I remember a
story of a friend of mine he was the
I might have shared this a few years ago
but he was a missionary uh and I don't
remember exact country was somewhere
like kind of South America I think and
and he um married a woman who was from
that that place and then eventually they
came to the states to visit like his
family and such and her first time she
walked into a grocery store
and like a modern America you know like
a Walmart or that kind of place and she
just started crying
not necessarily because of like oh wow
look at all this great stuff it was
actually from utter overwhelm
like I have never seen anything like
this like oh my God I just overwhelmed
and I think we don't even realize
right like we are the people of
literally not not even being hyperbolic
literally a million different products
and choices and options and I mean it's
like literally you've been on Amazon
right I mean just Millions
um this is this becomes kind of
problematic because what I want to
contend is that a this is actually
pretty recent phenomena at least in the
context of like world history you know
because I don't think we could say oh
it's just always been that way humans
have always been like this like I don't
know I think this is sort of peculiar to
like last few hundred years modern
Western culture you know
um but also I want to contend that
um it's like that this isn't um an
accident
like an accidental mishap in our broader
culture this is a quote from Patrick J
Dean and he's the political or professor
of political science at Notre Dame
he put it this way um it's a little bit
intellectual and heady but the ending I
think will will make sense so he says
modern society
teaches people
to hedge commitments
and to adopt flexible relationships
in bonds
not only are all political and economic
relationships blessings upon you
blessings
I love it
um not only are all political and
economic relationships seen as fungible
that is like replaceable
uh and subject to constant redefinition
but so here's the key so are all
relationships
and notice it's not just like human or
something all relationships to where to
place
to Neighborhood to Nation to family to
religion
modern society encourages loose
connections
loose connections you say those
connections to what to who oh that's
just it
everything
everyone everyone in your life
everyone
it encourages the
certain looseness
you know
certain
distance
I mean you love people you know I mean
like yeah over there you know but
like kind of not you know
it's a strange
it's a strange Society we live in and uh
you might think of it coming back to our
vow of stability it's sort of like in
modern culture we do have taken a vow we
just didn't realize it but it's like the
opposite the vow of instability
like that's our vow like yep I'm not
going to be anywhere
I'm not committed anything anyone
Anytime Anyplace any any nothing
just floating you know and it's like huh
interesting how's that working out
and and again this isn't like a a bug in
the culture
it's a feature
right it's not like an accidental mishap
like oh no oh gosh Western Society we
like accidentally did this thing and no
problem we'll easily remedy that like no
no no this goes like real deep real deep
into the whole kind of structure it's
essential as Dean points out it's it's
deeply encouraged and I don't want to
get too lost in why that is I think it
has a lot to do with economic
productivity
you know that like you it's the we sort
of it's that's the trade right we've
chosen like we want to be maximally
economically productive
you know and so and on the upside like
well it's worked we are like the
wealthiest
Society anyone's ever seen on the face
of the planet
you know so like in that sense it works
you know but like what's the what's the
trade because you know that's where we
always think like we'll get away with
something like you never get away with
anything there's always like the
Whiplash you know there's always the
other side or the Counterpoint to the
main point or you know how this plays
out and what's the what's the
Counterpoint well you you become Max you
get you encourage all that looseness
and then what's that other side well
um we don't feel rooted
we don't feel connected
we feel aimless and of course it makes
sense that's what we set out to do
you know I mean again maybe we didn't
consciously like this is just the it's
in the water so to speak it's just built
into being part of the culture and so
it's not like we consciously like you
know we're like I think I'll make this
decision it's more of you know you just
go with flow you know like you just
do the cultural cultural thing
and so we we tend to feel lonely we tend
to feel purposeless we tend to feel
disconnected we might just sum it up
like like this to kind of say it in a
tight way in a society of loose beliefs
and low commitments in replaceable
relationships
Christians must go against the flow we
need tight beliefs we need deep
commitments we need some strong
relationships
in other words if we want to be like
truly counter-cultural
in radical in a helpful way I'm not
talking about being obnoxious and like
pointing out everyone else is like
you're so wrong but like in a in a
healthful way in a way that actually I
think the the broader Society like needs
this needs some Counterpoint needs some
like whoa yeah let's bring a little more
balance or something that we've gone so
far that other way
um
then to do that we've in essence we've
got to start buying precisely the
opposite of what the broader culture is
selling
so okay so what does that actually look
like coming back to Ephesians 3 like how
will we become rooted people again
rooted in Christ's love well I want to
talk about two things a I think um
fairly obviously we've got a venture to
have faith in Christ
make sense you want to be rooted in
Christ's love I think we're gonna have
to venture to actually have faith in
Christ this is um as Paul says the table
Church
sexy Texas verse 16 says I pray
that out of his glorious riches he may
strengthen you
with power through his spirit in your
inner being so that what so Christ May
dwell in your hearts through faith
and I you know I will say I'm really
sympathetic here because because of our
culture
this for a lot of folks like if maybe in
any generation taking that step of Faith
venturing to have faith in Christ
in committing to follow him and to fall
in love more deeply with God and even to
commit ourselves to
um this Christian tradition and such
like that if in any generation was kind
of like a step you know like okay I'm
I'm going for it I feel the call and I'm
gonna do this you know
um but for us
I think it's just like it's been
magnified like for people now it just
feels like oh my gosh like I don't know
about this why because we we just live
in a time of such loose beliefs
you know it's like and we know all the
beliefs you know like previous
generations just had access to like
little information maybe the only
religious tradition they knew about was
like you know the one their their mom
and their grandmother and their
great-grandmother like everyone who just
practiced the thing you just did that
right and now it's like whoa we've got
we've got a big world out there
and so I think between that kind of Big
World between a lot of even just the the
kind of cynicism in the air
um it's just for many people it does it
feels like a huge step of faith and a
huge
um
yeah venture to have faith in Christ I
remember when I personally just went
through my own
kind of season of uh whatever you want
to call it wandering questioning
deconstructing Christian faith um this
is a while back now uh 15 years ago or
so and uh I had some friends like I was
I reached a point where I was I was had
pretty much had it with church and I um
I was attending but I was the guy who
just sat in the back row for my kids
whatever
and um
no judgment from the back that's fine
but for me it was a necessarily a good
sign you know
and um
and I remember I had some friends They
too had done a lot of deconstructing and
had literally they were kind of farther
down the road like they just deconstruct
themselves right out of everything you
know and um
and we I remember we would uh we meet at
the bar because we felt I don't know
maybe we felt edgy and uh silly
um but we met the bar and we would and
we basically we would talk and I mean
that part of it was kind of good because
we I don't know we had some shared
experience it was hard you know like
kind of leaving your tradition and it
was painful so there was something I
think good in it in the sense of some
connection and you could empathize with
one another but also after a while like
I noticed we were basically just
I don't know we would just talk a lot of
crap about Christianity and you know
like kind of poke at all of the soft
spots
um which are there you know you want to
look at church history or certain wings
of the church and their theologies
certain parts of it you know even today
I would be like oh yeah I don't go in
for that you know um but we would just
spend a lot of time like poking and kind
of mocking and you know
um
but we did that I don't know for for a
while I could meet with them every few
months we'd do this and after after a
while I um I realized like hmm well this
isn't this isn't really working
because
it was almost like I was trying to build
an identity around being against
something
you know which is sort of no identity at
all there's a quote from Theologian
Stanley Howard was he says this talking
about kind of modern educated secular
America he said we are the people whose
story is that we have no story
like that's us who who are you
or the people whose story is that we
have no story and I realize that's kind
of what I was doing I was like trying to
build an identity in life on like I
reject all the stories which ones every
single one just they're all crap and
they're dumb and certainly the Christian
story you know I was like that was I
just realized like this isn't this isn't
working like I don't I was missing like
a rootedness I was missing an anchor I
was missing an ideal of uh I mean in the
end I just think I was missing God like
the source of all that is in Christ like
an example someone a pattern my life
after and I realized after like a few
years this I just couldn't do it anymore
I just couldn't I remember I told my
friends like I'm a Christian again and
they're like what I couldn't believe it
just like you can you can't do that
where the people who have no story you
can't adopt a story that's you know all
the reasons why you can't do that
intellectually you know and I was like I
just
to
and there's a lot there's a whole story
as to why that is you know there's a lot
back underneath that
but
part of it I realized I said you know I
get it guys like from where you're
standing I'm like taking this huge step
you know like well how can you even know
if Christ resurrected from the dead you
can't prove it like a mathematical
formula you know I was like well here's
the thing from where I'm standing
I get it that to have faith is like a
step
but but also I think
to not Venture anything
I think just might be the riskiest
step of all
and I think that was what I was slipping
into
and so as I think back to last week we
were baptisms have Brandon and Jeremiah
and Eden and what were they doing
they're taking that step
venturing to have faith in Christ Church
let's do it I get it we live in a
secular age I get it it feels contested
we have doubts welcome to the club
everyone has doubts it's like we live in
Western Society where I mean we've drank
from the Waters of secularism and
skepticism and scientific method and I
mean all the things and I'm not saying
oh it's like bad I'm just saying it's
it's um
it's messed with us and it makes it hard
to venture it's okay
but like
let's still venture
you know so that's first a got a venture
to have faith in Christ
um B I'll move to this quickly we've got
a venture to have deep relational and
church commitments I'm going to move
very quickly to the relational side of
this this could be a whole other message
or meth yeah message but you know it's
just no surprise that in this kind of
society loose looseness that of course
any profound deep relational commitment
is really fallen on Hard Times
of course you know whether it's like um
marriage or friend even friendships you
know it's like sort of rare for people
to have like whoa you've been friends
for 20 years
you know because we again it's all loose
so it's sort of like oh we feuded so
it's over just move on there's always
more people
you know what I mean like it's just or
I'm having children that's another one
that's like whoa that's a big old
commitment oh it's not up for such
things you know and
um so you can see where right it it's
those are falling on hard times but I
want to shift to church
um
you know one of the this is something I
hear all the time and I at one part or
one part of me I understand it because
there's Church trauma and church can be
super crappy and people can be terrible
well the churches are a bunch of centers
so you know surprise it's like bad
things happen
um but
but there is something weird in this
this is the statement this I hear this
all the time from people I love Jesus
but I don't need the church
love Jesus I don't need the church
um
Becca can you uh
can you hear in that in light of
everything we've been talking about
tonight
can you hear where that's coming from
like can you hear the cultural kind of
influences in that right it's a hyper
individualism just me and Jesus
we got this everyone else
whatever I don't need you
I'll just do this on my own
you know it's like I mean it's just it's
you can read the Bible like it's not
really in there you know Christ
certainly didn't speak that way like oh
yeah who cares about the church you know
like no no there's
yeah there's something to this
we've got to be people of a story we've
got to be people
um learning to follow Jesus in the
context of Church community coming back
to Ephesians I want to focus on 17 and
verse 18. he says I pray that you being
rooted and established in love may have
power who
together
with all the Lord's holy people
to grasp how wide and long and high deep
is the love of Christ don't we often
read the scriptures as though they're
just talking to us as individuals but
like all the Bible is written to who
communities
over and over it's communities
and
well I'll say it like this rooted
Christians are always rooted together
with others
and that's that's one of those
counter-cultural things
that we struggle with
you know because there's something in us
As Americans that's like no I really for
sure don't need people
you know and um
it just ain't so kind of saying the
Texan way it just isn't so like we've we
need each other
so what I want to invite you to do
tonight Karen mentioned earlier the
little cards that you all have seen and
been thinking about
um what I want to do is just invite you
some of you tonight are like
um you've been here a while and you're
already doing like a lot of these things
you know
um others of you not so much maybe just
like your you know first or second time
and you're kind of like whoa I don't
know about this so it's just to be clear
if you haven't been here a while you
don't consider the table your church
home
um you are like off the hook this is not
for you know I'm really what I'm
speaking I'm speaking to the folks who
you know like you've been here a while
and you call the tail like the table is
your home and what I'm just you know I'm
speaking to you to us and I'm saying
like hey
let's be rooted
be rooted let's do this together so how
does that um how does that look I want
to invite you to three practices
um this year uh a is to meet
to meet to engage a meet-up a meet up
meetups are just our small groups and
they're basically just small groups of
people
who meet together throughout the week
for some support and encouragement and
connection uh and it's it's part of our
way of trying to be rooted in a very
rootless culture you know it's like even
if it's not just us as individuals then
it's sort of like the next level is like
the nuclear family and that's where the
connection ends in our culture sort of
like yo and then if you have like a
family that's it you know and so what
meetups are really about is expanding
that Circle of Care expanding our
connections with people and it's just so
powerful in our lives
um so we have groups that meet online we
have groups that meet in person uh and
actually we've needed a new in-person
group and I'm happy to announce that uh
Miranda and Ramon Delgado are launching
it right back there they're launching a
new in-person group it's going to be
meeting at the at the Barnes house
Stephen and Becky Barnes yes they're
hosting uh it'll be in Wiley so if you
need like a local group
well that's a great one because they're
like it's and they're just starting so
you don't have to come into the like oh
they're all close and know each other
and you know it's like it's just
starting so that would be a wonderful
one and uh and also they're coming out
of the Randalls group who's now shifting
to Allen so if you're like farther north
um that might be a really good one I'll
just say we have book clubs we have
there's all sorts of ones so
um we can be in touch if you're if I
yeah just encourage you to join a Meetup
second is to serve
serve others by joining a Ministry team
and uh of course Christ said the
greatest Among Us is the servant of all
and there is something really powerful
about
um just kind of stepping out and like
taking care of others in contributing to
something bigger than ourselves that is
like really profound and beautiful and
so um you can see on your car there's
like all sorts of places I mean as a
church plant obviously
um oh we got needs you know we got we
don't lack for uh you're like oh I hope
there's a place for me to plug in don't
you worry friend
um having said that we do have rotations
so it's not like you know you're like oh
now I have to serve every week the rest
of my life
um you know there's usually a lot of
them are every other or even like every
third or fourth week
um so yeah there's kids ministry and
Tech Team and hospitality and greeters
and Meetup leaders and host homes and
um yeah so I encourage you to to serve
and then third and finally is give
support the table financially
I know you know many of you already give
so tonight what we kind of wanted to do
was take some time just to reflect on
like okay what do we want to give this
year I realized for example for me
Maggie and I set up our like recurring
gift like three years ago and then you
know you just kind of set it and forget
it you know it's like ah it's there and
I realized like oh it'd probably be good
for me to like think that through again
you know
um and for some of us maybe our
financial situation has gotten Tighter
and so actually maybe God's calling you
to give less
and for others it's like oh my gosh
we're doing much better than we were
three years ago and so maybe you can
give more
um in the end this isn't a weird
pressure thing it's just we want to
invite you to support uh what God's
doing here financially with whatever you
can do for some people it's like you
know five dollars and for other people
it's like hundreds and that's just
um that's fun
that's fine just just whatever you can
whatever you can do
so
tonight
uh I want to just invite you
to
be a rooted people and the way we're
going to do this is we are going to
serve communion and so some of you if
you want to like fill out your card and
then take communion or vice versa that's
fine however whatever orb you want to do
it in but Karen will come up at the end
and kind of instruct you with what to do
with the card
um but I did want to transition us to to
this time of communion so this is the
table
not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
once you're done taking communion and
filling out your card if you guys would
stand with us we're gonna finish out
with a little bit more of that song from
Foundation
Nation
The Rock on which I stand when
everything around me is shaking
love never been more glad that I put my
faith in Jesus
she's never let me down he's faithful to
Generations
so why would he fail now he was
[Music]
there
he won
[Music]
he was
foreign
thank you so much
there we go thank you so much for
joining us tonight I hope that the
service was a blessing to you
um
couple of reminders uh your slips you
filled out make sure that your name is I
feel like a teacher make sure your name
is on it
and once it's folded up like this as
you're leaving you can drop it in the
bowl that's right underneath our digital
clock back there so just drop it in
there on your way out
um come find me if you have any
questions about it okay happy to answer
those for you
um also don't forget to read a letter
from a Birmingham Jail by Reverend Dr
Martin Luther King Jr we will post a
link to it on our socials tomorrow so
look for that if you want a quick way to
find it and read through it and don't
forget about the the path walk in the
park behind the Wiley Public Library
lastly I would love to give you a
blessing for the Road by way of
benediction so you are welcome to
receive this however you like sitting
standing hands out
whatever makes you comfortable
and I'll stand up here so I can see
everybody because I'm short
[Music]
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are and go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same Gifts of love and grace to
everybody you come in contact with be
blessed have a good night and we hope to
see you back here next Sunday
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna make it through
cause I'm standing strong on you
you I'm gonna make it through
my house was built on you
[Music]